Ngày 20 năm tâm tại công kết mạng, thủ đô là ha bà nà, bà chất hành trung ứng đàn cộng sản cuba đã lắm trọng tổ chức lễ kiện nghiệm
Tảm ứng năm của khánh Việt Nam, 1 hài thành chiến 1 nghiệm chiến chăm 4 miếm, 1 hài thành chiến 2 nghiệm không sản hà miếm nhằm, thêm hiện tình cảm đặc biệt với sân tộc Việt Nam, anh em.
Tham dựng bởi lễ có bị thư rưới nhất bà chất hành trung ứng đàn cộng sản cuba, chủ tịch nước cộng hoa cuba,
bà miếng em, tiết, khá nền, bà mù đet, phát biểu tại sự kiện, buộc trường ngoại giao, brut, norr, rô, rô, rùi ghét, bà rỡ nhấn mạnh.
Ngày 1 hài thành chiến 3 miếm, đàn dánh dấu sự hợi đồng của một trọng đường chiến thắng vang rồi.
Mình chứng cho thế giới, thấy tầm, póc chiến chỉ và cách mạng của rất tổ Việt Nam, anh hùng,
mà hồn cả định viên phủ chiến 5 sau đó, dù đến sải phẩm miếm năm thống nhất đất nước.
Công bộng mỗi với những thành tự vượt bật và phổ cùng là Việt Nam hôm nay, một đất nước tự hào và mạnh mẽ,
nước vào kiến bên mối, kiến bên vân mình của rất tổ.
Cuba và Việt Nam đã trở thành anh em trong tình bàn cách chiến đấu,
mô có thể đặc biệt cu ba Việt Nam được thế giện phó cung nói bất vụ của tổ lạnh,
vì đàn cắt trô, vì Việt Nam chúng ta sẵn sàng hiện dân cảm ấu của mình.
Sương vường ứng của nhân dân Việt Nam đối với sáng kiến hỗ trợ nhân dân cu ba,
của Việt Nam là cô cùng cảm lúc. Điều này đã vượt xa mọi ký vọng,
khẳng định lời nói, mà các nhà lạnh đạo Việt Nam luôn tâm liệm.
Đối với Việt Nam, bàn kết với cô ba là một lạnh lệnh từ chái tim,
cự chỉ hào phẩm và các bạn này thế giện gió nhất bàn chất thân thương và chân thành của tình anh em Việt Nam của ba.
Pê phần mình, lại sử lấy quan ngang bay tỏ trong hành trình phát triển dất nước.
Tình hiểm nghị đặc biệt, pô tư trong sáng của cô ba luôn là dìm tượng vốn chất là biểu tượng sống động của chúng như
cô tế chân chính. Đồng thời khẩm định các các của Việt Nam trong việc không ngừng buôn đặc làm xấu sách vốn liệu
bối quan hệ lịnh hịt chân thống. Bàn kết tạp Việt hợp phát toàn dịt với nhân dân cu ba,
vì nó thành tài sản buồ giá cho các thiếp mài sau.